it just feels like every time I win I
still lose
my mother used to say the universe
doesn't give without taking I'm going to
give you the thing you want most Barry
but it won't matter because you'll never
truly be happy trust me
I know you and I'm always right I still
win
I'm not coming back sister I can't feel
like I made a mistake I should have
saved my mom right now central city
doesn't need you to be Henry Allen's son
it needs you to be the flash central
city believes in the flash
this oh do I
who the hell are you my name is jay
garrick your world is in danger
we were never enemies Barry I'm not the
thing you hate hey youtubers it's
Charlie so ton of comic-con trailers to
get through I just I cut this down to
the new footage from the flash although
technically the footage that we just saw
was old footage that they just kind of
like redid to make it look like
something new so let's get going zoom is
coming so I'm gonna start with like the
really big announcements that they
confirmed it you know in case you
weren't following me on Twitter I live
tweeted a lot of these big things but
most of it were things that I've already
talked about like new characters that I
said that we're already coming and ideas
like the multiverse but the big thing is
that zoom is the big bad if you haven't
read the comics professor zoom was the
villain of the first season that's a Oh
Bart Thawne he was pretending to be
hunter wells Matt Lanter was the
original version of a Oh Bart Thawne who
then you know like sucked in the DNA and
became Harrison wells so you know Tom
Cavanagh playing two different
characters along with this other actor
here it gets a little timey wimey I know
they're gonna continue to do that in
season two Tom Cavanagh will be playing
dual roles although he didn't really
specify as to how that's gonna work like
he's not gonna be the exact same
versions of his characters that he was
in season one because he died he like he
was erased from existence he was a race
from time most of these new characters
though if not all of them are coming
from Earth too that's that's multiverse
territory I was so happy when they said
that they're using earth to to surface a
lot of the new villains and a lot of the
new heroes most notably Jay Garrick and
Wally West let's talk about zoom a
little bit so if you're not familiar
with the comics there's professor zoom
and then there's oom two completely
different characters professor zoom is
like the classic version of the verse
flash the Silver Age version of the
character he was created to be the main
antagonist for Barry Allen whatever
Barry Allen became the flash during the
Silver Age of comics when Wally West
took over as the main flash after crisis
on Infinite Earths they wanted a new
villain so they basically updated the
professor zoom character he just became
zoom that was Geoff Johns and it was
also
for character - it was hunter zolomon if
you watched some of my flash season 1
videos I talked about how they blended
the Wally West run in the comics with
the Barry Allen run so for instance
professor zoom on the TV show is kind of
an amalgam of zoom and professor zoom in
the comics like two different reverse
flashes the difference between those two
characters professor zoom was usually
painted is just like a pretty crazy
villain who just wanted to kill Barry
Allen erase him from time soom on the
other hand got severely injured in a big
gorilla grodd attack so he got really
pissed tried to use the cosmic treadmill
and in the resulting accident Zola Mons
body cut kind of phased out with time so
the way he travels like his speed flows
from a different place
zoom exists out of time so he like he
moves between the spaces and time it's
it's kind of a weird concept but
basically he's faster than the flash
because he manipulates time he doesn't
manipulate the Speed Force so professor
zoom super genius from the future zoom
Wally West's friend from the present who
gets twisted and tries to push Wally
West so that he gets faster and faster
so that he can save everyone which kind
of sounds like what a Bart Thawne was
doing on the show this season so let you
know like I said blending a lot of
different reverse flashes from the
comics the thing that made zoom a
villain is because he did really crazy
things so Wally West in the comics is
married to Linda Park zoom travels back
in time to try and kill her and she's
actually she's a character that we saw
in season one she shall probably be back
at some point so I know that's really
confusing but the big takeaway is that
zoom is way faster than any of the
Flash's and professor zoom that's why in
the trailer we hear harrison wells or
the voice of a Oh Bart Thawne or whoever
it is that's talking Tom Cavanagh voice
saying that there is something that is
worse than him trailers always lie a
little bit so he could be talking about
something else but it's totally possible
the Tom Cavanagh is not playing the zoom
character but I kind of hope that he is
the figure we see running in the trailer
he looks blue but it's really I think
it's the black racer the black racer in
the comics is a completely different
concept it signals the death of a
speedster it gets into the idea of the
negative Speed Force it gets way more
complicated so I think the TV show is
gonna simplify things basically if
you're one of the Flash's if you're like
part of the flash family and you see a
black racer it means you're getting
ready to die so it's it's like really
big
of all the things they confirmed at the
flash panel for season 2 Andrew
Kreisberg that the showrunner said that
they were most excited about zoom so
when Tom Cavanagh says I'm gonna give
you the thing that you want most I think
he's talking about earth - he's talking
about like alternate timelines alternate
realities Barry wants to change things
obviously if he were to make it to earth
- he would see a different version of
events that played out so people that
are dead on earth one which we'll just
call like the main earth for the show
might not be dead on earth - but on to
the next big thing Jay Garrick so
they've already cast the character he's
actually a younger version of Jay
Garrick he's not like an old Silver Fox
or anything like that but if you've read
the earth 2 comics then they kind of
reimagined the Jay Garrick character
just like all the other characters in
the show he's gonna be a mom of all the
versions of Jay Garrick you know from
all the way back to the Golden Age to
the current age they didn't say which
episode he was gonna appear in first but
zoom will definitely appear in the first
episode so we might also see Jay Garrick
in that first episode Wally West is
another question mark - they confirmed
he's coming on the show we just we just
don't know how so you kind of see where
this is going you know by the end of the
season or you know maybe even before
then we'll see a three-on-one flash
versus zoom fight Jay Garrick Wally West
and Barry Allen versus zoom they
unofficially confirmed killer frost but
they didn't say whether she was gonna be
from Earth - or if it was gonna be our
Caitlin they they kind of danced around
a little bit
danielle panabaker just said she
couldn't wait to play that character
again and they kind of smiled a little
bit like okay yeah we're probably gonna
see killer frost but they didn't say how
they were going to surface her like if
it was gonna be some twist in our
version of Caitlin or if it was gonna be
the alternate reality Caitlin Cisco also
pretty pretty much confirmed to be
coming vibe they didn't say exactly how
they were gonna visualize his powers but
it was gonna look like you know you know
how he was remembering the alternate
reality where he got killed it's gonna
look a lot like that so it's probably
gonna be happening is is that zoom as
the villain is gonna be changing the
timeline and Cisco's gonna be able to
sense when things have been changed next
new character patty spivot totally
confirmed to be coming on the show she's
gonna work in the police department
she'll be like Joe West's new partner
she'll be replacing Eddie I've already
done a video for her so I'll put a link
in the description if you haven't seen
it yet she was really big in the new 52
she was Barry's girlfriend for most of
the new 52
the really cool thing about her
character is is that she became a female
speedster I don't know that they're
gonna do that on the show probably not
but they might aside from that they just
said they're bringing on a couple new
rogues obviously I've already talked
about mere master and dr. alchemy those
are the only ones that they confirm but
I'm guessing they'll probably like one
or two others too they're gonna do a
golden glider captain cold episode early
in the season like that it's gonna
mostly focus on them and less on the
heroes Wentworth Miller's and is an
amazing actor he could lead his own show
so I mean they're doing it for that
reason just because he's so amazing and
it's such a great character but they're
also using the first half of the season
on the flash and arrow to set up legends
of tomorrow
Captain Cold we know is gonna be a big
character on legends of tomorrow so that
they're probably gonna feature the
legends characters in really big ways
just just to try and get everyone aware
of them that means we'll also be seeing
Hawkgirl a lot they did they also
confirmed Hawkman but I'm gonna talk
about him during my legends of tomorrow
video it really like the biggest
takeaways from the flash season 2 are
lots of time travel faster scarier
villain in zoom I mean they're gonna
change them a little bit from the comics
multiple speedsters and more new
characters from the comics so what I'm
gonna do is is like they did the exact
same thing for arrow they they announced
that Oliver is gonna become the green
arrow he's getting a new suit damian
darhk-- is the main villain anarchy is
gonna be like the lesser villain so do a
separate video for that be sure to
subscribe to get it there's just like a
whole bunch of trailers that I need to
get through because there are so many
what I'm probably gonna do is like first
thing tomorrow morning I'll do a
Deadpool trailer video then I'll do
arrow season 4 and then I'll get through
the rest I'll explain what the schedule
is gonna be and a lot of you are asking
about the panel footage from the flash
and all that of this stuff they
basically did like a three-hour block
where they just brought out the cast of
each show one at a time because they let
me backstage they didn't let me record
it so I'm still trying to get some some
panel footage but but essentially like
all this stuff I explained is what they
did it was it was really like 15 minutes
for each show they were just like these
are the new villains these are the new
characters we're gonna have a lot of fun
BAM
see you later so everything that
happened during the flash panel like I
said in this video like all those new
characters the new big bad really like
the zoom announcement was the big thing
if you like the flash in season 1 it's
gonna melt your brain in season 2
especially if you have read the comics
so while you wait for all the rest of
those trailer
videos to drop you can click here for my
breakdown of the Batman vs Superman
trailer like the new trailer and the
Suicide Squad footage and you can click
here for that panel thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow